the trump crony pardon list
is growing quickly i had 15 or so names
for you yesterday that were
moderately cronyistic but today's list
while smaller
is way more cronyistic donald trump has
now pardoned
jared kushner's dad charles kushner
remember
trump's daughter is ivanka ivanka
married to jared
jared is not just trump's son-in-law but
also an advisor
and jared's dad charles kushner was
previously convicted
for hiding personal political
contributions through organizations
for tax evasion and for witness
tampering it's quite a slate of crimes
and the witness tampering charge is wild
jared kushner's dad
charles kushner hired a prostitute that
he knew
what it means that he knew her it's not
clear he knew a prostitute
hired her to seduce his own
brother-in-law
set up a recording system for the whole
thing and then sent the tape to his
sister
he was ultimately sentenced for two
years served 14 months
then went to a halfway house and was
disbarred big fiasco
so trump pardoned him essentially a
family member
by marriage trump also pardoned paul
manafort
and roger stone both convicted in the
trump-russia investigation
both quote stayed loyal as they say
didn't give up any info on trump so they
got pardoned specifically after helping
to keep donald trump out of harm's way
exactly as we thought they would when
stone and manafort got pulled into the
investigation years ago
and then less prominently trump added
uh pardons for 23 other people yesterday
and three sentence commutations as well
so
are we surprised that donald trump is
pardoning friends and cronies no
of course not is there a bigger question
about presidential pardons that goes
beyond trump
no doubt no doubt about it but the way
that donald trump is using his pardon
power is so cronyistic
that even some republicans are saying
this is not good
republican senator ben sasse from
nebraska said quote
this is rotten to the core now to
everybody
saying to me on twitter and elsewhere
that hold on a second obama also
pardoned people
yes obama pardoned many people but
there's a key difference
which is that so far the majority of
trump's pardons are either people
directly connected to him
or whose crimes were connected to
helping him
that's not the same as obama there's a
debate about pardons to be had
let's not pretend that what donald trump
has done
with pardons is the same as what barack
obama did of the 65 pardons and
commutations
that trump had granted before yesterday
60 went to people either with a personal
tie
to donald trump or whose crimes
specifically helped trump's political
goals
or help to protect donald trump so
that's different
now trump and other trump loyalists have
insisted the president's pardon power is
absolute
and in a general sense that's absolutely
true the pardon power is absolute
but remember that trump dangled a pardon
for paul manafort
during manafort's prosecution that's
part of the obstruction that robert
mueller was looking at among other
instances recall that
during paul manafort's trial trump
publicly praised
manafort didn't rule out a pardon even
as the trial was ongoing and then said
manafort was brave
for refusing to break and that flipping
almost ought to be outlawed and then of
course
bigger picture the the other tragedy
with this
is that there are really
at least thousands of people maybe tens
of thousands i don't know
not trump's cronies but just regular
people mistreated by the justice system
who could really benefit from pardons
and trump is throwing in a few pardons
for people
serving long jail sentences for drug
charges for example but
it's really symbolic and meaningless
systemically and structurally
and if trump really wanted to do
something good
with this pardon power look at the
hundreds or even thousands of people
bullied unfairly by the justice system
convicted for drug crimes which have now
ruined their employment prospects
who could really benefit from a pardon
so always with trump
it's not just the cronyistic stuff and
the nepotism
but there's almost always a missed
opportunity to actually use his power
for good
expect even more pardons we're still
waiting to see whether
the preemptive pardons happen for his
family for rudy giuliani and
others that may not be until january if
it does
happen on january 1st huge
membership special to kick off the year
if you've been thinking of getting a
membership get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
you will get a perfect email on the
first telling you how to sign up